The Babylon 5 reboot Saga looks like
it's done it is not going to be
happening welcome to SRE your Sci-Fi TV
and mve a
[Music]
channel so I've been following this for
God 18 months nearly two years and um
I've just literally had an email from
somebody I know over at Warner Brothers
who has said look the final nail is in
the coffin of this project it's not
going to happen now but there is some
good news so hold on for that so what am
I talking
about 2001 now J M zinski first started
talking about a boots up complete reboot
of Babylon 5 this would be a complete
reimagining a
remake now that was received by many
with excitement by by some with some
trepidation a lot of people were maybe
thinking I don't want a complete boots
you know complete remake boots from the
ground up remake of this show I love
this show what I would prefer is if you
go back and digitally remaster the
original make the original look better
that would be cool you know new Space
Battles new CGI all that sort of thing
the problem being with that is just
wouldn't be profitable the cost of doing
that and trying to make it look like a
new show would be vast
and to be honest it probably wouldn't
have the audience that it would then
need unfortunately people don't get
excited about you know a a new version
of something like that in the same way
that they get excited about a new
project people also talked to um J
marinski on Twitter about why don't you
just do Babylon 6 why don't you do
Babylon 4 why don't you do something
else why don't you do sort of a
continuation and he basically kept
saying the problem is nobody wants to
buy Babylon 4 Babylon 6 and also let's
not forget that actually it says right
in the beginning the opening credits The
Babylon 5 was the last of the Babylon
stations so that also made it a little
bit difficult but J marinski is
fortunately bang on correct as he always
is that Executives over at Warner
Brothers and originally the CW were not
interested in a continuation of Babylon
5 they wanted a remake they needed to be
called Babylon 5 because then their
fragile little Minds that is all that
will sell so the CW originally was going
to make this series but then the CW was
bought out by a new company and they
basically changed direction that didn't
however though kill the project Warner
Brothers were still interested but then
Warner Brothers merged with Discovery
and started a massive cut cost cutting
exercise that cost cutting exercise
basically meant several projects were
cancelled at various different stages
bgirl was cancelled even after it was
finished virtually finished not quite
but
virtually
so it seemed that Warner Brothers were
not going to be paying for this project
but I've been able to tell you
exclusively over the last 18 months or
so that that didn't kill it Warner
Brothers were interested in trying to
find someone else to pay for it
basically they would produce the new
Babylon 5 series with j mrozinski and
that we would still get the Babylon 5
project I've told you that initially
Apple were very interested in this and
I've actually told you initially Warner
Brothers were even considering just
putting on to Max um actually when
Babylon 5 the original series was reown
on Max a couple of years ago it did
really really well I've then told you
though that actually Apple we're
interested but apparently they've got a
bit of a reputation that they express
interest in everything
um so we don't know what happened there
but then I actually did tell you that
Amazon were apparently interested they
saw this as a perfect project for freee
a provide a channel they're basically
trying to find new projects for all the
time at the moment and really do want to
heavily develop in it over the next few
years so it looked like it could
actually end up on freee and actually to
be fair I thought that was a perfect fit
I could 100% see a new Babylon 5 series
on freey it would have a limited budget
but the original did so I think you know
in my head I'm thinking it would still
feel like Babylon 5 that would be quite
cool but now I can tell you that as it
stands today Babylon 5 a liveaction
series is not going to happen unless
something changes dramatically at Warner
Brothers or basically Amazon decide to
fot the bill for this but at the moment
they're not going to this isn't going to
happen but the road home animated movie
did very well and that is what the fans
were screaming for it was a continuation
an addition to the original series it
did really well and sales were actually
slightly better than expected so Warner
Brothers are exploring more animated
movies I'm actually being told one is
already in serious development and it
will be probably kept quite secret until
the animation side is done the actors
that came back for the um Road home
movie will return again
and this again will be a continuation of
the Babylon 5 Saga so it will be set at
some point within the babyon 5 um run I
actually think that is the best way I
know a lot of you guys really really
don't like animation and I can
understand why to be honest because it
can be quite irritating it's not as good
as live action let's be honest um but
Warner Brothers have a really good
reputation of producing these type of
projects really quickly and really well
and I have to say I loved the road home
on the whole I love that it was a
continuation of the original series I
love it was an addition to the story and
I thought it was done really really well
I like that they used actors and voice
actors that were respectful of the
original characters and I liked
basically how the whole team behind
Babylon 5 got together Bruce Brock lner
is still brilliant even though you can
kind of hear in his voice he's now an
older man but you know maybe they could
do something with AI to tweak that a
little bit if they really wanted to I
would actually though love to see
something um from the mimari wars from
the beginning of the conflict you know
something that's a slight prequel to The
babyon 5 Series that' be very cool um
I'd also love to see more with Sinclair
and stuff that was a storyline that
never really got concluded so yeah do
more with that that would be great as
well but guys what do you guys think
about this news please get over into the
comments I think this was expected to be
fair after just over two years waiting
and the what's happened with the CW and
then what's happened with Warner
Brothers Discovery I think this is a
project that was a vanity project
possibly for people over at the CW
originally um and I don't know I just
can't help but feel that it was not the
best idea to begin with if I'm really
honest um but that doesn't don't but
don't get me wrong j Mar kazinski was
involved and that man is a genius and
I'd have watched anything he produced
anything at all so I don't
know it just it always smack me as a bad
idea but it might have been awesome but
guys get to the comments and tell me
what you think are you surprised by this
or actually did you expect it and do you
want to see more of the animated movies
did you Eno the road home did you enjoy
it and you know do you want to see more
of that because at the end of the day
it's the only way we're going to get a
continuation of the original If we're
honest get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you think if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out and you'll never miss any of our
new videos also you can go to
patreon.com citre where most of our new
videos do Premiere first and you get to
see them without the adverts finally go
to c.o. which is our dedicated website
and we do articles based on a lot of our
videos I'm doing this video today as I'm
going into work I'm now late but you
know as I get the information I'll get
it to you as always please stay safe and
I'll see you next time
[Music]